[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Marcellus Wiley the
former NFL All-Pro defensive end of
course his podcast more to it you can
listen to it danpatrick.com or wherever
you get your podcast
let me start there
we're what eight weeks away from the
first playoff game which is plenty of
time you would think if you do bring in
obj is he worth all of the coverage that
he's received
absolutely you got to think about Odell
Beckham Jr in several ways one is just
the production you expect from Odell
Beckham Jr which would be a third
receiver maybe even number two receiver
on your roster so that's positive but
what people are not really respecting is
in football there are teams there have
been a dynasty with the New England
Patriots where the team's Talent level
they play greater than the sum of its
parts like you can look at it in terms
of production and talent and then
there's another X Factor that makes that
team play Above their heads with Odell
Beckham Jr added him to a roster all of
a sudden you have a roster that may have
X amount of talent but guess what
they're gonna now have an X Factor
because he is electric he is juice guys
believe in him and there's nothing we
can say in the outside media that's
going to change the minds of those
players who are calling him who are Tech
him and who believe in him because we
all have played the game of football in
the NFL and we all have not touched the
heights he has and that super stardom
translates in a locker room he still has
impact okay but give me the downside of
bringing him in now considering you are
one of the elite teams in the NFC is
there a downside there's a downside
personally to Odell Beckham and his
brand and his future going forward
because last time we saw him it was
coming from Cleveland and we had our
doubts and he answered all those doubts
by going to the Rams and changing their
team their Dynamic and almost winning
the Super Bowl MVP if he could have
stayed healthy so now we're right back
where we were when he left Cleveland
we're doubting him again if he comes
back and fails in this moment this is
going to land on Odell but the team that
takes the chance on Odell oh it's a
smart roll of the dice because there's
nothing he can do to your team to
sabotage it because Odell's already been
been through that in terms of kicking
the net with the Giants and the white
flower in London and et cetera so he's
not coming to disrupt your program only
this can go wrong for Odell the player
this just stand during a team meeting
minutes ago the Jets players were
informed that Zach Wilson is not
starting against the Chicago Bears
I started the show by saying I would not
tread lightly and worry about his
feelings by benching him I can't lose
that locker room Marcellus you've been
in that locker room and I can't treat
one guy differently who hasn't earned to
be you know that right to be treated
differently what do you think of this
move yeah I'm with the move um Zach
Wilson did it to himself in two ways
obviously by his performance and
performances like he had a resume of bad
performances enough to make them even be
in this position but when you come out
and they ask you did you let down your
defense did you disappoint your defense
in that feudal effort and you say no oh
you've lost everybody because now you
have put the coach you have put
Management in the position to answer
that question correctly and everyone
knows you did and it was a chance for
him to own it and then the mercy rule
kicks in you know how it goes when
you're playing the dozens with your
friends or you're in position where
you're get called out if you do The
Eight Mile if you talk about yourself
first then they're going to be nicer to
you in response to talking about your
production your effort but what he did
was act like hey I'm exempt from all the
ills from that performance that is a
team effort and guys are looking at him
like dude we did our part you didn't do
your part so since he didn't own up to
that they had to go out there and make
sure he's not the starter yeah I can't
lose the locker room because of one guy
and if he's he's that sensitive to
criticism and I'm going to bench him I
I've heard analysts say oh you can't do
it you might lose him well if I lose him
over this
then am I really losing him no that's
good math like I don't know what school
everyone went to but uh you know I'd
rather lose one than 52. you know it's
just that simple 52 guys are sitting
there looking at him everything he says
is starting to sound Charlie Brown
because we're not listening to Zach
Wilson anymore and he's certainly not
going to lead us consistently with his
production so it's like now hey coach do
the easy thing it's not even a hard
decision listen to your players inner
voice and now express that to the team I
want to run down the hall of fame list
the class of 2023. hmm so it's just yes
or no
okay
all right I get five in total are we
doing this or just yes no uh just yes or
no okay Eric Allen
no Jared Allen yes Willie Anderson yes
Ronde Barber
no
oh
I know that's tough I know Anquan Bolden
no
Henry Ellard
no London Fletcher
yes surprisingly Dwight Freeney oh hell
yeah stop playing James Harrison yes
Rodney Harrison
no definitely that hurt Devin Hester
yes
it's a good thing we don't have just
five for you
and that's the toughest part about it
all Dan it's like they all qualified to
some degree to be in the conversation
but then you got to just be almost mean
you almost got to like disrespect to get
them in because everybody can be a Hall
of Fame but go back to Rodney Harrison
how much does this have to do with
testing positive for Peds Wow you went
there first I went to San Diego first
and the lack of Pro Bowl the lack of
Team success despite them still going to
one Super Bowl I remember when I became
a charger and that was the story about
Rodney great player but not fully
respected or fully understood from The
World At Large like football players are
like yo he's a beast and then everybody
else was like yeah if he's a beast why
doesn't he have ABC so I always knew
that that would come back to haunt him
but of course the Peds you know how I
feel about that once you're on the Peds
you should be on the baseball list in
terms of being at home yeah but but
Rodney what one of two players in the
history of the game with at least 30
sacks and 30 interceptions yeah I wonder
how many he would have had without the
PD
yeah but I get it like you you're still
a great player I just don't know how
much the nitrous helped you and since I
don't know that answer uh I guess can't
be the guy in position to gift you a
Hall of Fame candidacy Antonio Gates in
there if if you know he's denied it but
he he got suspended yeah okay gates
gates Rodney you got a little charger
section over there
just put them all over there I love all
those guys but can't do it Tori Holt
the closest no I have like almost a yes
Andre Johnson
Yes Albert Lewis
no
Robert Mathis
no close close close close close close
you can't put everybody in
Darrell Rivas yes Steve Smith Senior
I thought I had the closest no to Yes
um
he's really winning by every time you
talk to him or listen to him broadcast
his help but I would have to say no my
hall of fame no Fred Taylor
Ah that's my boy
um
he was a monster who got he got so
underappreciated you want to put him in
just to get his flowers let me just say
yes I Gotta Throw one in there yes Joe
Thomas Hell Yeah by by far the easiest
yes yes Zach Thomas
yes but the second easiest yes that dude
was silly
Heinz ward
no
look at you
the whole NBC family you're like I know
you don't like anybody on there uh no
Chris Collins but no I would just
um DeMarcus Ware yes Ricky Waters no
Reggie Wayne
yeah
yeah
no no no no no okay no no Vince Wilfork
yeah really it's hard to measure what he
had to do
okay that's the problem Patrick Willis
oh yes my God quick too he did it fast
Darren Woodson
God
hmm
yes yes no no wait was too long there
Rodney Harrison was just in my ear like
dude you're gonna let Darren Wilson in
and not me but they're an anchored some
amazing teams on top of being an amazing
player all right what do you expect to
happen in these uh Thanksgiving like the
biggest surprise is going to be where in
these three games
ah let's stay with the Giants and Dallas
one what a match up you know a lot of
times that turkey Bowl match up with the
Dallas Cowboys you're just sitting there
in your food coma but this one you're
gonna be alert for the biggest surprise
is going to be
that Dallas is going to have to respond
to their own greatness the biggest
response is going to be that they will
uh we saw Minnesota go to Buffalo just
beat Buffalo come back get destroyed by
Dallas you're like where's your response
Dallas goes to Minnesota and smokes them
and now we're saying where's your
response I think we're actually going to
see it which is going to be surprising
to many people because we always
question the maturity of the Dallas
Cowboys not their talent I think they
respond and when you listen to the
podcast uh we're talking to Marcellus
Wiley it's called more to it on The Dan
Patrick Podcast network not only talking
football
but you also talk the real reasons why
Kyrie Irving apologized
yes yes I'm talk about I learned this
from my therapist slash my wife I'm 45
years young at the time so I lived the
entire life with the old school model of
apologizing you only apologize when
you're wrong if you did something wrong
say you're sorry move on and then I got
enlightened to the second level of why
you apologize it's when you hurt someone
and they felt slighted no matter what
your intentions were no matter if you
were right or wrong and it was a
different level of understanding for me
Epiphany so Kyrie Irving who claims who
says who professes he cares about
Humanity he cares about the human race
he cares about all not a right or wrong
conversation to apologize the old model
the new model they felt slighted so now
you fully matured have to come to that
realization I need to apologize not
because you did something wrong exactly
but because they felt slightly
Happy Thanksgiving to you and the family
and uh proud to have you on the program
and and the podcast Network Marcellus
appreciate it man I see you five pounds
bigger next week let's do it Marcellus
Wiley the former NFL All-Pro defensive
end and his podcast entitled more to it